-Across the British West Indies
and the whole British empire,
the slave trade and the
institution of slavery
was officially
abolished in 1834.
This is conventionally
said to mark
the end of bondage, the rise
of quote unquote "liberalism".
The origin point for an
eventual freedom for all.
For the four years
preceding that date,
a halfway house institution was
erected called Apprenticeship.
During the
apprenticeship period,
enslaved people across
the British Caribbean
were put into a
new legal category,
half property, half person.
They were made into
debt peons, paying off
half of the price of their
manumission through their work.
The other half would be borne
by the British state, which
authorized a mind-bogglingly
large compensation
package for the slave owners
of the Caribbean in 1834.
Damned as property
and damned as persons,
the so-called
apprentices were made
to compensate their enslavers
for the slave owner's
loss instead of the
other way around.
Slave owners, sensing the
end of their way of life,
what Jean Rhys in
her beautiful book
describes as the
garden of quote unquote
"dead flowers and gardens
gone to the bush" unquote,
seemed intends to whip,
compel, and coerce
the last drops of life and
labor out of a decaying system.
But they did not
confine the whip
to the bounds of the Caribbean.
In fact, they began to whip,
compel, and coerce laborers
in the work houses of
Ireland, and Scotland,
and southern England.
But more significantly, a
regime of force and coercion
arose across Asia
and Asia Pacific,
and eventually across
the interior of Africa.
Often, through
kidnapping and trickery
and the use of brute
force, new laborers
were brought from distant
lands to the plantations
of the Caribbean at the
coming of abolition.
These workers, mostly
from Asia, were
called quote unquote "Coolies".
They were contract
laborers or sometimes
debt peons--
there's a difference
and I can talk about that
after-- working under the dread
of corporal punishment.
At the same time, the plantation
itself mutated into new shape
and began to travel
the face of the earth.
It is in this context
in British Guyana
that the following events
took place in 1836.
The plantation of Vreed en
Hoop, peace and hope ironically
enough, that's
what it was called.
A plantation in
British Guiana was
owned by this man, John
Gladstone, who lived in London.
On that plantation,
Rose, a black laborer
of the plantation Vreed en Hoop
was deposed by a fact finding
committee about events that had
just recently transpired there.
She testified
quote, "I recollect
some Coolies running away and
going to Berbice long time ago.
It was two or three
months after they came.
I heard they went to Berbice.
We were free before they
went away--" meaning this
is just after 1834.
"Adonnis, a black slave foreman,
and Ramsing, an Indian Sardar,
or an overseer for the
Coolies, were sent for them.
The Coolies returned before
Adonnis and Ramsing came back.
I saw them when they were
brought to the estate,
but I did not see
who brought them.
They were carried
to the sick house.
Next day, they flogged
all those that ran away.
They brought all
from the sick house
together, and took them to
the negro yard to be flogged.
I saw them flogged.
Mr Jacobs was the only
white man present.
The driver for
them flogged them.
They were flogged
one after the other.
They got more than three licks,
but I cannot say how many,
amd cannot say
that they got five.
Their backs are not
cut, but in bumps.
They appeared to me as
severely punished as my mateys
were during the
apprenticeship when flogged.
They're flogged
with a cat, a cat
o' nine tails whip, the
same as was formally in use.
Some cried and some did not cry.
There was no blood.
When the blacks
have been flogged,
I have seen blood on
their backs," unquote.
Notice some salient features
of this first hand account
from Britain, who
first, the speaker
is a black slave woman
speaking about the attempted
escape of Indian quote
unquote "Coolies"
or indentured servants
from the plantation.
Second, the audience is
a fact finding committee
convened in 1838 to determine
whether practices of slavery
were continuing, even after
the abolition of slavery.
Third, notice that a black
and an Indian observer
are sent out to
capture the absconders.
Forth, notice Rose's
comparative analysis
in which she remarks the
ways that Indians are now
treated like black
slaves, whipped
in the same negro yards,
kept in the same sick houses,
flogged as severely by the
same cat o' nine tail whips.
But she also mentions
this difference.
She sees no blood
on their backs,
which is different from what
the slaves used to experience.
The outcome of
the investigations
into these forms of
punishment so reminiscent
of slavery, the torture on Vreed
en Hoop where the following.
The general manager
of the estate,
the manager of the Coolies,
and the medical officer
were all indicted and
convicted a brutal assaults
before the inferior criminal
court of British Guyana,
and neither fined
nor imprisoned.
The result however, for
this man John Gladstone,
the slave owner of Vreed en
Hoop, who lived in London
is a study in contrast.
He went on to become one
of the most important power
brokers in London just
at this time, fashioning
policy for the whole
British West Indies, as well
as the British East Indies,
and for the labor migration
system that connected the two.
This plantation
owner John Gladstone
remained a very important man.
He stood at the center
of plantation empire.
Here we have in the 1830s,
an unprecedented conjuncture
and entanglement of once
distant peoples and histories,
bound together by commercial,
military, and political ties,
linking Britain, the
Caribbean, Africa, and India.
We see emerging ideas
about race, labor, economy,
agriculture, and ecology.
My central argument is that
the labor relations, land
relations, financial
institutions,
an agroecological
relations so characteristic
of Caribbean slavery,
did not die away
in the 1830s with
abolition, but rather went
through a genuine
mutation, which
allowed them to travel
like a metastasis
to new parts of the earth,
and to implant and expand
across the global south.
Caribbean forms
of force, control,
and industrial agriculture were
disimbedded through abolition,
and traveled eastward to the
Indian Ocean, Asia Pacific,
and sub-Saharan Africa.
The planter class of
the British empire,
and although I'm
not an expert, I
would surmise the French
and the Dutch empires
as well-- that planter
class found life after death
in the east.
The events taking
place in the 1830s
have important implications
for the world we live in today.
The unprecedented events taking
place on the Vreed en Hoop
plantation in British
Guyana, and eventually
across this whole belt that
has been called the world
plantation belt,
signaled the rise
of a new global
agroecological regime,
based on an
accelerated enclosure
of crop lands across
the global south
as well as the expansion of
settler farming across North
America and the white
settler colonies.
So plantation slavery
ends in the 1830s
in the British empire, and
other empires follow after that.
This period from
the 1830s onwards
is often considered to be
the age of the Industrial
Revolution, the age
of liberal empire,
or the age of liberalism.
And what I'm interested
in is in some ways, what's
happening on the plantations
and how the plantations spread
exactly at that time,
exactly at the time
that conventional
wisdom tells us bondage
was coming to an end.
The period from
the 1830s to 1930
saw an eruption of
plantation farming, marked
by the production
of export oriented
agricultural commodities that
fed the Industrial Revolution.
The agricultural
products that went
into making refined sugar,
soap, rubber for tires,
tea, clothing to
clothe the workers
in European industrial cities,
as well as the shipping
bags used to package
goods and commodities
to be sent overseas,
were produced initially
on colonial plantations
using forced
labor of different kinds.
The lands on which of these
plantation enclosures appeared
were confiscated through
militarism, taken away
from sovereign groups
considered to lack sovereignty
due to their perceived
racial inferiority.
These agricultural commodities
were sent by railroads and then
by sea to factories in Europe.
Up to the 1830s,
Europe's trade with Asia
was primarily marked by what
is called mercantile trade
by commerce and
exchange of silver
for commodities such as spices,
or porcelain, or textiles.
But beginning in the
1830s, we see the rise
of the new aggressive,
militarized plunder
and conquest of Asian
lands and the destruction
of native sovereignties
that actually
echoed that previous
period of slavery
and what took place on
the west coast of Africa
and across the Americas.
As part of this big change,
what Kenneth Pomeranz calls
the quote unquote
"great divergence,"
huge populations were displaced
across the Bay of Bengal, which
it's right there on the end.
Across the Bay of Bengal,
and across the South China
Sea on this side of
the map, and were
sent to other parts
of the earth to work
in industrial agriculture
at suppressed wages.
A portion of this displacement
was inter-regional
with tens of millions of
Africans, Indians, Chinese, and
Japanese laborers boarding
ships for the Caribbean,
the American West Coast, Latin
America, and the shores of Asia
Pacific.
And I wanted to also mention
that at the same time
the 1830s, if you go what's
happening here in the Atlantic,
this is also in some ways the
eruption of the slave trade.
It's taking place to
the American South,
it's also taking place
especially to Brazil.
So that factors into
the story as well.
But there is even a larger
number, and obscure number
of laborers who are migrating
regionally or internally
to work on nearby emerging
plantation frontiers that
were opening up across
Asia at the time.
The Asian and Pacific waters
in addition to the Atlantic,
served as a labor well for the
emerging agroecological regime.
Simultaneously, huge amounts
of credit and finance capital
were disinvested
from the Caribbean
and now directed to agrarian
frontiers in India, Ceylon,
Malaya, Vietnam, Indonesia,
Hawaii, and the list goes on.
Here, we have a global whirlwind
of the plantation complex.
A churning storm of circulating
bodies, investments,
and institutions around the eye
of London, Amsterdam, Paris,
and other European centers
of finance, credit,
and joint stock companies.
A century-long
agroecological regime
emerged around the 1830s,
veiled by the terminology
of liberalism and free trade,
which actually depended heavily
on the expansion of course,
of force, occupation,
and waged bondage to all
corners of the earth.
The Caribbean
moved to Asia, just
as Asia moved to the
Caribbean during the decades
of the plantation empire.
The plantation complex
invented in the Caribbean,
entailed a racial system of
land appropriation and labor
control.
It entailed the
enclosure of lands
for the intense cultivation
of single crops,
a practice called
monocropping, which
were sent into the
international market.
The plantation complex
involved the outlay
of huge amounts of
credit, which served
as the lever for vast
infrastructural projects
of agroecological
transformation,
including land enclosure,
irrigation works, railways,
and the dredging
of deep sea docks.
In short, the plantation complex
invented in the Caribbean
from about the 1600s
to the end of 1700s
mixed together racism,
colonialism, finance capital,
mercantile capital, militarism,
and agricultural science
in such a way that allowed
that complex like a metastasis,
to pick up, disembed itself,
and travel to new places.
I wanted to show you in a
series of three graphs or maps
visually, how that plantation
complex actually traveled.
So 1710, this is
kind of the beginning
of the story if you like,
where the plantation complex
is mostly here in the
Americas in North and South.
Then we come to 1838, which
is right after the time
of abolition and you
see that the new centers
for the plantation
are the Indian Ocean,
certainly Mauritius, parts
of West Africa, parts
of East Africa.
And then finally, when it comes
into its full fledged form
by the 1920s, it's now
spreading across the whole band
from the Tropic of Capricorn
to the Tropic of Cancer,
across what would come to
be called the third world.
So what traveled along with
this plantation complex?
As the plantation complex
traveled from the Caribbean Sea
to the Indian Ocean
and Asia Pacific,
we see the transfer
and adaptation,
the mutation of forms of forced
labor including the chain gang.
This is a chain
gang that you see
depicted, the preference
for women on the fields.
This was a phenomenon
of slavery actually,
that as slavery became
a more mature system,
there was a preference to
employ women as opposed
to men on fields because they
were more easily exploitable,
thanks to both cultural
forms of patriarchy
as well as capital quote unquote
"modern" forms of patriarchy.
The use of the task wage--
you can ask me what that is,
but it's a different
kind of wage
that was often
used under slavery,
and during indentureship.
The enduring presence
of coercive overseers,
there he is on his horse,
with their paraphernalia
of rods and whips and the use of
physical violence as a subsidy
to make labor cheaper
and more pliable.
We also see the transfer of
horticultural and botanical
methods as evidenced
by these master manuals
from the Caribbean
that began to circulate
across the new plantation
frontiers of Asia
by the mid 19th century.
Some of the most important are
for example, Monnereau, Elias
Monnereau indigo planter.
He was a planter in the
1700s in Saint Domingue which
became Haiti.
And this document,
the Indigo Maker,
became one of the most
celebrated manuals in places
like Java, Ceylon, Bengal in
the 1820s, '30s, and '40s.
Laborie is also here,
who was another coffee
planter of Saint Domingue.
A planter from
the Saint Domingue
before it became Haiti again.
And this document became
especially important
for example, in Ceylon
and Malaya where there
was a lot of coffee planting.
There is also Alvaro Reynoso,
who was a planter in Cuba
and a specialist in
sugar production.
And this manual again, travelled
to parts of Bengal, Malaya,
Ceylon, Indonesia, Philippines
as sugar production was begun
there.
So one interesting point is that
places like Jamaica and Haiti
were not just significant
within their own empires,
but they were seen in some ways
as the scientific experimental
hotbeds, or think
tanks if you like,
for how the modern industrial
plantation should work.
And they had an afterlife much
after the end of the slave
regimes in Saint
Domingue or Jamaica,
in a very different
part of the world.
After the abolition of
slavery in the 1830s,
the slave system of
agricultural production
is not consigned to
history and is also
not seen as some kind of
abomination or aberration.
Rather, it becomes a focus of
intense official fascination
by for example,
British businessmen
and government
officials investing
in the new colonial
frontiers of Asia.
The East India
Company, for example,
was smitten with what it
called interest in the quote
unquote "West India method" and
it invited a series of slave
overseers from cotton
plantations and sugar
plantations in Mississippi,
Louisiana, Jamaica,
and other islands of the
Caribbean to south India,
to move to-- they funded their
travel to south India, Bombay,
Bengal, in order to set
up what they called model
farms in the 1830s and 1840s.
These overseers brought machines
such as the ones depicted here
like the gin house,
or the vacuum pan,
which were quintessential
with Caribbean plantation
production.
But they also brought with them
their whips their, hot houses,
their sick houses,
their dungeons,
their modes of labor control.
We also have the transfer
of plantation technologies
from the Caribbean to India,
including technologies relating
to seeds and biota, sugar cane,
cotton, coffee, cocoa, tobacco,
gutta-percha, which was used
to make telegraph lines.
The ways of perfecting
tea, indigo, jute,
rubber, all of these botanical
and biological innovations
involve circulations
of knowledge
between the terminy
of the Caribbean
Sea and the Indian Ocean.
So I wanted to spend now
the last portion of my talk
moving in a different
direction, which is less
talking about what was
migrating, which we know now
where the laborers, the seeds,
the machines, the technologies,
the conceptual languages.
And I want to talk more
about how things came
to migrate in the first place.
What I want to
discuss is what are
the conditions of possibility
for these circulations.
I want to talk about
the movements of capital
and of capitalists.
Here, capital, which
is often invoked
as an ill-defined an
abstract term, here I
would like to define it
in a more concrete way.
I want to talk about this
in terms of understanding
how the power to coordinate
the movement of value
over geographic space developed.
How the power to disembed,
extract, and accumulate value
over time was obtained.
What were the dynamics
of that power that
managed to create that
whirlwind that I showed you
a few slides ago, that
managed to coordinate
that vast and unprecedented
interpenetration
between the two hemispheres
of the global south.
So that's what I'd
like to move to next.
And to do that, let's return
to the story of John Gladstone,
who we met at the
beginning, and consider
his social and
political constellation.
John Gladstone was
a Scottish merchant,
a businessmen from
the English periphery,
who accumulated immense wealth
and made a name for himself
quite literally you'll
see, among the gentleman
and the capitalists of his time.
He literally bought himself
into the aristocracy obtaining
through purchase a
baronetcy in his 60's.
He was born a commoner with
the last name Gladstones.
He soon reinvented
himself, dropping
that S which smacked
of commonness,
and thereby made himself
in this gesture, singular.
His trades on the cotton
exchanges of Liverpool
went well, and he
soon began investing
in slaves and plantations
in the Caribbean.
He eventually put capital
into the East India trade.
Among his children
were three sons
of note, Robertson, William,
and Thomas, one of whom
went on to become the
famous prime minister.
By 1830, Gladstone who
had garnered vast wealth
through renteerism and
trade, especially thanks
to his plantation investments,
his investment in logistics
and shipping, and his
involvement in the Liverpool
cotton trade, now decided it
was time to enter the highest
rung of politics.
In 1830, now a
very important man,
he penned a letter to the then
home Secretary Robert Peel,
explaining that if
slavery were to be ended,
there would need to be some
new form of cheap labor
that would have
to take its place.
Abolition and freedom was
not incompatible, he argued.
In fact, freedom went along
with the continued project
of compulsory labor for the
quote unquote "lesser races."
He proposed replacing slaves
with indentured laborers
from Africa.
By the time he went to
implement his plan in 1834
at the time of abolition,
now with the blessing
of the government, he in
fact obtained his workers
from indigenous tribes in India.
By this time, Gladstone
had expanded his plantation
holdings and he sent
his son Robertson
to Demerara or British Guyana
to oversee his new plantations.
He also had a nephew,
FM Gillanders,
whom he sent to Calcutta.
So here's Gillanders.
And also in Calcutta
at the time,
was another one of
his nephews Robert.
And those two formed
a company that
did the bidding of
Gladstone at a distance.
In 1834, the British government
compensated slave owners
for the loss of
their human property.
I mentioned this
at the very start.
Based on a huge loan taken out
from a banking syndicate led
by the Rothschilds,
the British government
went into debt to the
tune of 20 million pounds
at that time, which today has
been estimated by experts to be
in today's money between
13 billion pounds and 200
billion pounds, depending on
how you think of that amount.
And I can tell you details
about how this is calculated.
But it was a vast
amount of money.
It was equal to 40% of the gross
domestic product of Britain
at the time.
It was a huge debt.
Using that slave
compensation money,
Gladstone was able
to enlist his family,
in order to transfer
this capital now
to the new frontiers of empire.
He enlisted his
nephews in Calcutta
to secure a set of
Indian indigenous
people, the so-called
Hill people Bihar--
a term that the
British were using.
He obtained to ship, he
took that group of Indians
first to Mauritius
where they started
working on the plantation
of one of Robert's cousins
who was a plantation
owner in Mauritius.
And then from there,
there was another group
that went on to British Guyana
reaching British Guyana in 1834
and making possible the story
that I began with with Rose,
and what she observed
on the plantations.
So here, we have the
beginning of an answer
to the question of how
this genuine mutation
of the agroindustrial
order took place, beginning
in the time of abolition.
This eruption of the
plantation complex.
The unprecedented eruption
of finance capital
into the hands of
ex-slave owners
gave them the power to invest
into new parts of the earth.
They invested into the
railways of the United States
and the railways of Scotland,
and the railways of India.
British banks began investing
in Central America and South
America, but they also invested
into the plantations of Asia.
And as much as capital
is an abstraction,
this story shows us that it is
embedded in family relations
and friendships in the relations
between uncles and nephews,
fathers and sons, and in
the culture of the planter
class that actually stretched
across the whole British
empire.
The life of capital
is a family affair.
Now during this time, Gladstone
who was located in London,
began to sit at the
most important tables
of the British government.
And he was involved in
informing policy that in that
affected both the
Caribbean basin and the Bay
of Bengal together.
Gladstone, as well
as his sons and close
friends were involved in
formulating key elements
for the 1834 New Poor Law,
which affected the quote unquote
"paupers" of England.
He helped to define the
apprenticeship system
through a series of
select committees
that were called by Parliament,
which I've schematized
here, as well as policies
for the rise of the indenture
system.
All of this beginning in
around 1834 and then kind
of playing out of
the next decade.
So we see here
what I'm beginning
to think of as a kind
of Gladstone clique.
And don't really have time to go
into so much detail about what
these lines represent, but they
represent either family bonds
or friendship.
In red, we have
actual slave owners,
people who had slaves
in the Caribbean
who received
compensation, and who
went on to then define
what apprenticeships
should look like.
Or went on to define how trade
should take place East India.
Or to foreign policy
for the establishment
of the plantations across the
Bay of Bengal in the 1840s.
So this group remained
extremely influential in what
some historians call the rise
of the second British empire,
which is the British
empire after 1830s.
Here for example, is
another image showing you
a variety of
directors and chairman
of the East India Company
who were slave owners, who
received compensation in 1834.
And who therefore were obviously
carrying with them a lot
of conceptual baggage,
but also a lot of wealth
from that huge payout that
the British government gave
in that time.
Caribbean slave owning capital
travelled to Asia after 1834
and established a net of
ligaments and connections that
in fact, linked the Caribbean
and Asia in an unprecedented
way.
And I came up with some
schematizations of this.
I'll try to explain
what this is showing.
And this is thanks to help that
I received from two colleagues
in London, Nick Draper
and Chris Jessupson,
as well as work that was done
by two of the Radcliffe fellows
at here.
And a lot of time reading
the compensation report
and looking through
trying to cross reference
with the archives of
the East India Company.
And what this shows, each
of these dots is a person.
And there are 97 dots there.
There are 97 slave
owners that we've
traced thus far who actually
transferred their capital
from the Caribbean to Asia
sometime between the 1800s
and 1840.
So there's a kind
of a 40 year image
or perspective that is being
presented here in one graph.
And I wanted to first--
maybe we can just
look at this in terms
of the gestalt of it,
and you see that some
of the main connections
are made through the
East India Company.
They are also made
through Bengal.
You see that some of the main
connections the Caribbean
are coming out of
Jamaica, but also Granada.
And you also see Guyana
coming up very, very often.
Now to make this make
a little more sense,
I pulled out just a few examples
from within this group of 97.
And then there
are more, but this
is the beginning
of trying to trace
in a very concrete way,
the extent to which
this slave capital, this
compensation capital
was being transferred.
I give you four examples.
First, Leonard Ray who
was born in Jamaica.
And he owned plantations there.
And he departed a for Bengal
in the 1840s, where he started
sugar plantations in Garapur.
And by the late 1840s, he
then moved on to Malaya,
establishing coffee
plantations and he
became known in Malaya
as the quote unquote
"father of coffee."
Thomas Boyce Tipler, born in
Aberdeen Shire in Scotland.
He was sent to Jamaica-- this
is a very interesting story--
he was sent to Jamaica
at the age of 15
to apprentice on a plantation,
just at the time when
slavery was ending.
Just at the time when there
was fear that the West Indian
method was going to die away.
He then went on
at age 18 in 1838
to Ceylon, where he went on
to make a name for himself
as the quote unquote "father
of Ceylonese coffee."
And he also did a lot of work
in developing the migrant labor
system in Ceylon
for the government.
Julie Dartie, a planter
of French origin
who redirected to her capital
from the slave plantations
into shipping, and
began investing heavily
in the shipment of indentured
slaves to Mauritius.
And Giddan Dutai, at least
one planter that I've found.
I've been looking very
intently for more,
but this is one example of a
planter from Saint Domingue who
then travels across the imperial
boundary from the French empire
to the Dutch empire.
And we meet him
next in Java, where
he's an owner of coffee
plantations there.
The effect of all of these
planter migrations and capital
transfers was the propagation
in different and new parts
of the earth of diverse features
of this plantation complex
that I outlined earlier.
Global economic
mutations take place
because of impersonal abstract
forces, yes, on one level,
of course.
But they also take place
because of material, personal,
and interpersonal
movements at another level.
In the 1830s, to the 1850s,
we see a proliferation
of experiments by
small scale planters.
The rise of a decentralized
network of finance.
Racial forms of domination
and exploitation
traveled through this
planter diaspora.
We see the use of techniques
such as whipping, boxing
of ears, the using of prisons,
the using of hot houses,
the use of gang labor and task
work, as I mentioned before.
And all of this is also
traveling through these family
ties and friendship networks
just as much as the capital is.
Now I want to conclude
the story by seeing
what happens to this
plantation complex by the time
that we reach our own days.
From the 1870s to the 1930s,
we see the consolidation
of this agroecological
regime under the sway
now of new great
multinational corporations.
The rise of multinationals
and the pumping in of finance
capital allows for the
expansion of modern industrial
agriculture all the
way now from the Tropic
of Cancer to
Capricorn, across what
will become as I have said
before, known as an actress
category, the third world.
Unilever, Tate and Lyle,
Sunlight, Booker McConnell,
Tetley Tea which is
like a litany now,
Lipton's, Duncan's, Ford,
Firestone, Dunlop, Michelin,
Good Year, United Fruit
Company, Alexander and Baldwin
thanks to Tiano for that, and
other such huge multinationals
began to agglomerate their
plantation holdings worldwide.
And in many parts
of the global south,
these companies actually
became inseparable
from the state itself.
British Malaya went from
having not a single rubber
plant to producing more
than 500,000 tons of rubber
per year between 1900 and 1920.
Unilever cultivated
74,000 hectares of land
the size greater than New York
City in oil palms between 1911
and 1918 in the Congo.
The Ford corporation
tried and failed
to turn 15,000 square
kilometers of the Amazon
into a huge rubber plantation
in the 1920s, an area
that they called Fordlandia.
But what was happening
behind the branding?
We see in the sources
the way that the terms
black and niggers come
to be employed in company
correspondences and in
corporate boardrooms,
to talk about ethnic
communities as diverse
as Bengales, Filipinos,
Afro-Caribbean,
Indo-Caribbeans, and Fijians.
In this parlance,
black refers to a kind
of laboring body on the
fields subject to bondage,
requiring discipline, requiring
civilization through labor.
I wanted to show you
two more images here.
So these are images from
this 1920s 1930s period,
and scholars talk
about in some ways,
the staging of the photograph.
And here we have
the blacks, and we
have the white overseer or
the white corporate visitor
on the plantations.
Here is Tate and Lyle, which
is still today a huge sugar
producer.
This is an image from their
big plantation in Caroni.
And again, we have this in
a very quintessential kind
of colonial scene.
By the 1950s, economists from
across the third world argued
forcefully that this expansion
of the plantation complex first
thanks to footloose planters
and the help of the colonial
states, and then due to the
machinations of multinational
corporations, resulted in quote
unquote "de-industrialization"
and the enduring independence
third world nations on Western
economic institutions.
Now we live in a
post 1830s world,
I would like to argue
after this talk.
The Green Revolution of
the 1930s to the 1970s,
the period that follows
what we might think
of as the age of
plantation empire,
was marked by the rise of a US
dominated regime of genetically
engineered seeds,
petro fertilizing,
which means the use of
petroleum product derivatives
to make the land more
productive, but also poisons
and obviously kills biological
life at the same time.
As well as the coming of great
mechanization to plantations.
All of this was
actually integrated
into the national
policy directives
of many new third world
nations during this time
of the Green Revolution,
which was also
the time of decolonization.
But beginning in the 1980s,
this Green Revolution period
was superseded by the
strident re-involvement
of Western banks and
multinational corporations
in redesigning agrarian
frontiers across the earth.
The period of new enclosures
in which we still live.
And that's not my
term, that's a term
that many ecologists
and critical economists
use to talk about our present.
Argentina, Brazil, Indonesia,
the Philippines, Thailand,
southern parts of Africa have
borne the agroecological brunt
a transnational finance.
Today, food security
in developing nations
across the world has
diminished, not grown,
as many of these nations produce
more agricultural commodities
for international markets than
staples for their own home
consumption.
The ILO estimates that
500 million people today
work on plantations,
but this does not
include the millions of
undocumented children
and often, undocumented
women who are
a major part of this economy.
In fact, that 500 million
is a gross underestimate.
Undocumented trades
in shadow economies
and informal employment,
whether in the agricultural or
non-agricultural sectors,
comprise more than half
of all employment
in the world today.
It is said that
likely the majority
of the undocumented workers in
the informal economy are women.
In other words, more
than half of the laborers
that make this world economy
run are hidden from our sight.
Unrecognized by governments,
unregistered by statistics,
but also easily
invoked as scapegoats
to explain economic turmoil.
Our consumption depends
on for as its condition
of possibility on the continued
and accelerated dispossession
and enclosure of sovereign
cultural domains.
And just to make
that point, that's
what this graph is showing.
That the rate of
increase of enclosure
has gone up over time,
including to our own time.
It hasn't gone down, it's
not as if this process
has abated or come to an end.
Our consumption depends as the
condition of its possibility,
on the continued and
accelerated dispossession
and enclosure of
sovereign cultural lands,
the purchase of human
labor at discounted rates
by the use of bondage and force,
and the large scale destruction
of the ecological web of life.
But poets, artists, writers,
activists, and every day
surviving people within
the plantation complex
and within the vast
realm that some scholars
call the realm of
disposable life,
or the disposable economy.
Even by the everyday
acts of survival,
make the point that there is an
inscrutable way in which life
resists, regenerates,
endures, reassembles,
and it does so as it resists
the violent pursuit of enclosure
and control that
masquerades as progress,
and has done so for centuries.
And that's my talk.
Thank you.